[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture une émission dans
laquelle nous vous présentons les
rendez-vous yvelinois culturel au
sommaire aujourd'hui et tout s'éclaire
est un roman co écrit par deux auteurs
yvelinoise un livre pour se questionner
sur sa mission de vie florence le yen et
les listes pour qu'ils nous présenteront
leurs ouvrages
toujours dans la littérature mathilde
florence originaire de poissy vous
parlera de sa toute première bd sorti en
janvier dernier le choix dans les dettes
illustre des rendez vous ratés des
applications de rencontre enfin le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueilli la compagnie les filles du
renard pâle pour son spectacle résiste
faute de pouvoir être joué devant un
public
la représentation a pu se faire devant
des professionnels et je vous le disais
en titre 2 heavy noise de conflans
sainte honorine ont sorti leurs romans
et tout s'éclaire qui est sorti en 2020
à la suite de leur premier ouvrage tout
et des gens toi florence le yen et ellis
pour qui vous êtes avec nous ce soir
pour nous présenter ce livre
enfin bon j'espère que ça va vous êtes
donc co auteur de ce livre et tout
s'éclaire élise vous y mêler fiction et
développement personnel pourquoi alors
pourquoi parce que en fait on a vraiment
envie que le roman cuisse mieux faire
passer est expirée demander ce que l'on
dispense dans nos pratiques de
thérapeutes en fait là un exemple très
concret cette histoire de louis qui est
un carrefour 2,7 sa vie professionnelle
et qui va faire appel à un coach pour
faire le point et notamment grâce à
l'outil de wikileaks gaye qui est un
outil du bilan de compétences il va
vraiment identifier ses talents se
reconnecter à ce qui fait sens pour lui
et se reconnecter aussi assez joie
d'enfant qui sont vos bouquins vont
créer à l'intérieur donc justement comme
vous à les élever et il ya un deuxième
personnage s'appelle antoine qui lui
suit un autre chemin dont on va parler à
florence elle est si florent si vous ne
me semble pas les rues en fait on suit
alors
donc antoine lui de son côté ils
auraient brocéliande et notre but
c'était de montrer comment en fait se
connecter au sens de sa vie se connecter
à la nature et comment prendre sa place
dans le monde à un monde qui est en
pleine mutation aujourd'hui donc c'est
vrai qu'avec la crise du colis de notre
livre a encore plus se trouver du sens
en laye qui avant mais je pense que ça
peut être une aide pour le lecteur pour
trouver les clés en fait pour donner du
sens à salies et contribuer au monde
aussi en pleine mutation qui se présente
à nous tous justement j'allais dire
qu'est ce qui vous a inspiré pour
l'écriture de ce deuxième roman est ce
que c'est vraiment ce qui se passe en ce
moment la crise sanitaire ou c'est autre
chose alors on a écrit avant donc c'est
ça qui est assez drôle
en tout cas disons qu'ils avaient battus
opportunément en ce moment et ce qui
nous a vraiment motivé en fait et
inspiré c'est nos parcours
professionnels de coach pour élise et
pour moi dans la pleine conscience et
l'idée en fait d'associer la quête de
soi et une spiritualité accès incarné en
lien avec la nature et
aussi avec cette idée de la co-création
gpo d'essay aussi admise à busnes
charmeau sur la co-création six tubes we
la co-création c'est vraiment ce qui
nous anime avec florence a fait
plusieurs années qu'on se connaît on est
d'abord à nice où collaborent sur plein
de choses et on s'est aperçu que co créé
c'est à la joie développer ses talents
propres et mettre ses talents commun au
service d'une cause qui nous dépasse
quelque chose de plus grand et par les
temps qui courent on pense qu'on est
vraiment une fille banque est très
importante à développer justement là
vous vous dites vous êtes co auteur donc
vous travaillé ensemble sur ses livres
qu'est ce qui vous a amené qu'est ce qui
vous a donné l'idée de travailler
ensemble répond notre amitié le fait oui
en fait on a une association pendant
quelques années à conflans et s'appelle
public ou donc on a commencé à se rendre
compte qu'en fait on arrivait à
fonctionner ensemble très bien en étant
toutes les deux fixations projet à
chaque fois ce qui compte pour nous
c'est d'aller au bout du projet et on
arrive le résultat à m
par nos égos de côté en fait la cokerie
et cette fois aussi mon envie de parler
dans mon livre je te laisse compléter je
sais pas si oui la co-création cette
impulsion qui pousse en fait les gens à
se relier en fin de compte à donner le
meilleur de soi au service d'une cause
qui est plus grand que moi donc voilà
les héros dans le livre vivent tous un
chemin à la fois
hertz personnel et qui peut se lier et
voilà ils ont l'idée d'associer leurs
talents pour pour faire à avancer
là une cause commune qui est la quête de
soi en rapidement et en quelques mois ce
que vous avez des projets à venir
ensemble oui plein parce que vous avez
un exemple par exemple alors là il ya un
compte qu'on est en train de finaliser
donc ça peut être un conte pour enfants
qu'on a chez qu'elles sont aboutis on a
aussi un nouveau projet de sa de livres
c'est pas pour tout de suite et puis à
les ateliers je te laisse en parler
ouais on essaie à chaque fois de mettre
en pratique ce qu'on dit dans les livres
dans des ateliers soit en distance yale
soit en présentiel et donc là pour eux
et tout s'éclaire bas ont organisé au
printemps
d'abord en distance yale et puis dès que
l'on pourra en présentiel dans un lieu
nature très très sympa qui pourra
vraiment faire plonger les gens au coeur
de même et de la nature
voilà merci à hélices pourquier et
florence le viennent d'avoir été avec
nous je le rappelle
coauteur du livre et tout s'éclaire les
applications de rencontre c'est le sujet
choisi par mathilde de florence pour sa
toute première bande dessinée le choix
dans les dettes
originaire de poids si elle est décrit
18 témoignage de rendez-vous qui ont mal
tourné mais sur le ton de l'humour à
l'illustratrice nous présente son
ouvrage regarder
[Musique]
il ya un petit peu de l'histoire qui me
concerne 2 ou 3 et après sinon c'est des
amis ma mère aussi a participé et j'ai
fait un appel à témoin sur les réseaux
sociaux donc j'ai également des gens que
je connais pas du tout qui ont bien
voulu témoigner donc ça c'est assez
chouette c'est un peu un truc de
référence pour à la fois que les gens
puissent apprendre ou su reconnaître
dedans et à la fois dédramatiser un peu
le fait que je vais traiter avec humour
c'est pour que je pensais quand même pas
trop trop grave
après vous je dis pas qu'il ya des
choses qui se passent des fois ça doit
arriver mais voilà c'était pour détendre
un peu les gens autour de sujets il ya
une personne qui a envoyé son frère
jumeau à sa place parce que en fait ils
assument et plus du tout et il a perdu
son courage avant d'aller au rendez vous
puis des trucs aussi de deux dents un
rendez vous entre deux personnes et puis
là il ya la personne avec qui l'une des
deux est en couple depuis sept ans qui
débarque alors que le parti n'est pas du
tout au courant
la bd est sorti le 15 janvier aux
éditions lapin et elle est à retrouver
sur le site de l'éditeur bien sûr mais
aussi en librairie et sur les
plateformes en ligne avec ou sans
barrière c'est le titre du concours
vidéo à destination des collégiens
organisée par le département des
yvelines
le but sensibiliser les jeunes aux
gestes barrières coeliaque guettent son
goût vous êtes avec nous ce soir oui
bonsoir un soir qui peut participer à ce
concours célia et bien tous les élèves
des collèges publics et privés des
yvelines ont pu participer puisque les
inscriptions sont terminées
ce sont donc eux douze équipes réparties
sur 11 au collège
parmi eux on retrouve le collège blaise
pascal de plaisir jean racine de saint
cyr l'école ou encore jean françois
champollion de voisins-le-bretonneux les
élèves encadrés d'un professeur référent
doivent maintenant envoyer une vidéo de
deux minutes sur la thématique des
gestes barrières
l'important en faisant ce concours enfin
ce secours souhaite c'est justement
sensibilisés à ces gestes barrières pour
que à la fois au sein du collège mais
aussi à l'extérieur mais aussi à la
maison
ils puissent les respecte et venir
comprendre l'importance ces gestes
barrières et puis communiquer aux autres
leurs autres amis le leurs parents leurs
familles et donc la vidéo ne doit pas
forcément être sérieuse la nouvelle peut
être humoristique ou bien décalé les
collégiens ont jusqu'au 14 mars pour
déposer leur vidéo
ensuite un jury composé de parents
d'élèves d'institutionnels deux
représentants du département ou d'élèves
détermineront quelles sont les
meilleures vidéos on aura une notation
en fonction à la de l'originalité du
caractère un peu humoristique ta qualité
du scénario est donc quatre prix vont
être attribués c'est vers minuit le prix
yeux du héros masqué qui concerne bien
sûr justin j'imagine le port du masque
le port du masque le prix sociable mais
distant consacré à la distanciation
physique
le prix au nickel chrome sur le lavage
des mains et le prix sans barrières sur
des gestes barrières en général alors
mille euros seront attribués au collège
gagnant qui favoriseront des projets ou
des actions pour la santé merci célia
goetz angot d'abord est avec nous on
retrouve bien sûr pour le cette fuite ce
week-end vendredi les 11 et 12 février
dernier le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a accueilli la
compagnie est les filles du renard pâle
pour son spectacle résiste si la
représentation n'a pas pu être joué
devant un public et les artistes ont pu
présenter leur travail aux
professionnels regarder depuis le 1er
novembre les théâtres s'organisent pour
ouvrir leurs portes aux compagnies pour
filmer les spectacles ou être vu par des
professionnels au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 15 spectacles
ont été maintenus dans ces conditions
objectif que les spectacles soient vues
entre le mois de novembre et est
aujourd'hui à des dizaines et dj dire
des centaines de spectacles ont été
créés beaucoup l'on va plus jouer
c'est dans ce cadre que la compagnie les
filles du renard pâle a présenté son
spectacle réside
une représentation destinée aux
professionnels et aux programmateurs le
spectacle de funambules était à
l'origine conçu pour l'extérieur
la compagnie a c'est toute la semaine le
théâtre pour adapter ce spectacle pour
la salle puisque ni les lumières ni
leçon nous sont exactement le même qu'à
l'extérieur on est vraiment dans des
conditions de jeu très différentes
donc voilà ça fait partie des choses que
l'on arrive à faire pendant se dire ce
confinement mais pendant cette fermeture
des théâtres sur scène un régisseur une
chanteuse et une funambule cette
dernière évolue sur une structure conçue
spécialement pour le spectacle
il a appelé le fil instable donc l'idée
c'est un fils qui se casse la gueule qui
s'incline qui bouge qui va dans tous les
sens l'idée c'est de tenir sur le fil
coûte que coûte que coûte quoi qu'il
arrive et de voilà de faire passer aussi
le message de quoi qu'il arrive même
s'il feel it on me voilà qu'il ya plein
de choses qui se passent à 20,2
finalement pas se réapproprier l'espace
tel qu'il est devenu et puis bah tout ce
qui peut nous arriver dans la gueule bah
finalement en retirer quelque chose de
positif et puis continuer à se battre
continue à aller de l'avant pendant le
spectacle le fil s'élèvera à 4 m 85 une
petite hauteur pour johan klein et il
est pas très haut vol il ya pas mal de
techniques donc moi je reste que sur le
fil il n'y a pas de plateforme de façon
à structure ya pas de plate forme il n'y
a rien donc je suis à z que sur le fil
ou sur le balancier et sinon après je
vais dans les grandes traversées je peux
monter pour l'instant de planck les
fesses et jusqu'à 40 mètres de hauteur
et puis sur des grandes longueurs de 120
mètres de long ou plus la compagnie
reviendra à saint quentin en yvelines en
septembre pour retrouver son public
elle présentera une version rue du
spectacle
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture merci
de nous avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv
78 et d'ici là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]